Veme: So this talk is aimed
at a 2.01 level.
That means we're expecting
that you've got some experience
with App Engine,
you've probably
written some code
and that you probably
also have written some code
using the task view system.
If you haven't,
that's okay.
You should be able
to keep up
with what I'm
going to say today,
get the gist
of what's going on.
So let's just go back
and look at App Engine history.
So App Engine
is a great system
for writing
your web apps.
You can manage them,
scale them automatically.
You can write them
very easily,
you go straight
out of the box,
start up for free
if you like.
One of the limitations
that we have
is that user face requests
are limited to 30 seconds.
So the task key
was initially introduced
as a method of overcoming
some of this limitation
and also offloading
some of the work
that users really shouldn't
have to wait for,
so things like data start
updates or URL protocols,
things that just do some
cleanup tasks in the background.
So here's a mental model
for you of what a task queue is,
how we'd like you
to view it.
The tasks here are indicated
as the colored boxes
and the queue here is sorted
in order of increasing ETA.
That's the earliest time
at which we'll attempt
to push the task
to your application.
So I'm showing you here
a model for pushing tasks.
So tasks here,
HTTP requests,
you can see
on the right hand side,
there's an instance
of your app
that's adding a task
to the queue
and that blue box is going
somewhere in the back there.
And you can also see
that the task queue service
is taking some tasks
from the queue,
and pushing those tasks out
to other instances of your app
for execution.
So this is
the push model.
You have control
over how many tasks
can be running
concurrently.
You have control over the rate
at which they're executed,
and the task queue service
handles everything else for you.
So the way that you define
these queues is quite simple.
You've got queue.yaml
or if you're using Java,
queue.xml,
in which you can specify
the name and the rate
and other parameters
like the retry parameters.
The tasks are gonna be added
to the queue using an API,
call it taskqueue.add,
very simple one
for both Python and Java.
You can see
that in the Python case,
you refer just
to a URL equals foo,
use a bit more type information
in Java.
The task queue system
will push those tasks,
those URLs to your app
at the rate that you specified
and the instances
are scaled at the,
just automatically
by App Engine itself.
So any failed task
that is any task
that has a return code
not in the 200 range
is automatically retried,
and you also can exert
some control
over how those retries
are managed,
what the back offs are,
how the back offs should grow,
what number of retries
are allowed
before the task
would fail permanently.
So here's another bit
of history.
This is the way
that our product has grown
in the last couple of years.
So you can see that
after the App Engine launch,
it was a gap of about a year,
and then we were able to launch
task queues as a labs feature,
it was called at the time,
that's experimental.
And Java support was added
a quarter after that,
but initially,
we had limitations,
maximum QPS was initially 20 QPS
across all of your apps.
That was relaxed later
to maximum of 50 QPS per app,
and then maximum
of 50 QPS per queue.
So at that time,
you could have ten queues.
That was a big increase.
Finally, we were out of labs
at the end of last year
and we had maximum
task running length
increased from the standard
30 seconds up to 10 minutes.
Then we were increasing
our QPS per queue to 100.
That's the maximum allowed,
and today, we'd like to tell you
that you're allowed
500 QPS per queue.
So today, we really want
to focus your attention
on the first really large
new feature
in the task queue system.
And this is a new model
for the queues.
It's called pull queues.
So these are new,
as I repeated.
They have been mentioned
in a couple of the other talks
already.
For example, if you were here
for the backends talk,
you might have heard them
mentioned.
So here's the basics.
Push queues, the tasks
are actually HTTP requests.
In pull queues,
tasks are just data.
So the meaning of that data
is completely up to you
as the programmer
who creates the tasks
and will also be doing some work
in response to the tasks.
So workers are leasing
tasks from the queue.
That's in contrast
to the push model
in which the task queue system
just calls
those HTTP requests
on your application.
So instead of the task queue
system,
deleting tasks
because an HTTP request
returned a return code
in the 200 range,
it's up to a worker
in a pull queue
to delete the task
manually.
And scaling is also
your responsibility
when you're using
the pull model.
So in the case of push queues,
the App Engine itself
was going to scale
the number of instances for you
depending on load.
In this particular case
of pull queues, it's up to you
to configure the number of
workers that you need.
So I said
that workers lease tasks
and there's a reason for that,
and that's that a worker
might crash
while it's working
on a task.
And it would be a bad thing
if the task was lost
and no one else was able
to complete the work.
So you, if you crash,
the lease will expire
and at some time after that,
another worker will be able
to lease the task
and complete the work.
But, if the task is actually
the cause of the crash,
and will be causing crashes
indefinitely,
you can actually limit that.
You can say no more
than this many tries
at leasing the task
before the task is considered
to have failed permanently.
That prevents
infinite crash loops.
So let's just take a quick look
at the API.
First I'll cover Python
and then I'll cover Java.
But I'd also like to
give a plug to Go.
Although I don't have
a slide on it,
we have an implementation
in Go.
So in Python, the big change
is that a queue in queue.yaml
that you specify now
can be specified with mode pull.
If you don't specify mode
at all,
it defaults to push.
So pull and push are the two
valid values for mode.
When you're adding tasks
to tell the system
that you're actually adding
one of these data-only tasks,
you say,
method equals pull.
So here you can see,
you know, task add,
payload equals hello,
method equals pull.
Now, leasing tasks,
we return a list of task objects
back to you.
You can lease
more than one at once.
So here we're just trying
to lease three tasks
for 30 seconds.
The first parameter there
is the length of the lease.
And finally,
with that list of tasks,
you can use that also
as the argument to delete tasks
once you've finished
doing your work.
So q.delete tasks.
And in Java, things
are very, very similar.
There's just
a few more things
that are a bit more idiomatic
for Java there.
So here we use our builder
patent for task options
to add a task,
and we use an object
that specifies
that this is a pull task.
Leasing tasks returns
a list of tasks handled.
Task handles are a slightly
different abstraction in Java
that represent tasks
in storage vs. task options
which represent the tasks
before they have actually
been created in storage.
And we see lease tasks
again.
This time, we can specify
using the time unit.
And finally, deleting tasks
is done in a loop,
but a very simple loop,
as you can see there.
So I want to give you
a mental picture
of what's happening
as you are leasing tasks
so that you can see
that in this particular case,
time is going to be flowing.
The tasks are always
in the queue until deleted.
So I'm indicating again tasks
as the colored boxes.
And I'm also indicating
with that now pointer
that the,
that's the current time.
And then everything
to the left of that pointer
is available for lease.
Everything to the right
of that pointer
is considered
already under lease
and therefore,
you can't lease those.
So here is a worker
attempting to lease three tasks
for 30 seconds.
We can see highlighted there
the three tasks
that are available.
So in this slide,
we see them having been
delivered to the worker,
but also moved past
the now pointer
into the leased section
of the queue
and they actually moved
to a point that's 30 seconds
beyond the now pointer
as it exists.
So we see the three tasks
come down.
Now the worker is going
to work on those tasks,
is gonna do whatever work
was encoded in them,
presumably
the same programmer
wrote the code
for inserting the tasks
as is writing the code
for the worker.
So the interpretation
is very much up to you.
So now it's up to the worker
to delete the tasks,
so uses those three
colored rectangles
and we see them gone.
But you also see that the
now pointer has moved on
and the next leased tasks will
possibly return three as well.
So I'd like to give you
a demonstration here
of pull queues in action.
So this is one of the models
that is pretty good
for pull queues.
And this is when your tasks
are considered to be
very small items of work
rather than large items of work.
And we want to lease
multiple of them at once
so that we can batch
the work together
and gain some efficiencies
on datastore and other APIs.
So in this particular case,
the tasks are votes.
And we're going to be
tallying the votes
and storing them periodically
back to datastore.
But we don't want to be doing
a datastore operation per vote
because that may well use up
all of quota very quickly.
So we're going to reduce
by accumulating votes first.
So let me just move across
to voter later.
And this is something that
all of us have opinions on.
It's all very tongue and cheek,
so I don't hate any
of these languages, actually.
So selecting one of them
is considered a vote.
And you'll notice that the tally
hasn't updated immediately,
however, if I refresh
the task queue,
I can see that some of you
have already been
putting votes in as well.
And these are the votes
currently in the queue.
Now, if I do another refresh,
we should see the tallies
changing.
There's somebody here who's
decided to add a vote for Java
and another one in
for Perl.
And you can vote as often
as you'd like.
So this one may decide
just to curl in a loop.
No, it can't collect.
That's all right.
Right, so let's just move on--
to some of the code.
So firstly, we have
our boiler plate, appl.yaml.
Everything happens
in main.py.
It's a very simple
application.
And queue.yaml,
you can see defines a queue
and it's called votes
and it's in pull mode.
And our handler
is at the root level
is just the vote handler.
That's where on the post,
you can register a vote
on the get.
You just simply display
the form for voting
and the current tallies.
There's a tally handler as well,
and that's called
only by the tasks.
Sorry, it's called from cron,
but it's not meant for users.
This is the one that actually
is going to do the work
of pulling the votes from
the queue and updating tallies.
So just a quick look
at vote handler.
You can see there
in the post method,
that I'm adding the tasks
to the queue with method pull.
Now, the workers,
well, we've got lots of choices
for workers now.
Just in the previous talk,
you heard about backends.
Backends could be workers.
Also, cron tasks
can be workers.
Also, long running tasks in
a push queue would be workers.
It's really up to you.
So in this case,
for this example,
we're gonna
specify it in cron.
So you see there, every minute,
the tally handler runs.
So the data model
is pretty simple.
It's just account,
the key name is
going to be the language name.
And there's
a convenience method there
that actually
will update the count.
Storing, we do
that convenience method
in a transaction.
And finally, the bit
that you've been waiting for,
which is the loop in which we
are going to be leasing tasks,
doing our work,
and then deleting them.
So it's as simple
as you could imagine.
First, we get hold
of the queue.
Then, in a while, true loop,
we just say, lease tasks,
try to get 1,000 of them
at once.
A 1,000 is the maximum
that we're allowed
and we'll lease them
for five minutes.
If there's any kind of failure,
five minutes from now,
those should be available
for another worker to lease.
So if you didn't get anything,
you might as well just return,
and the next indication
of this handler, via cron,
will pick up anything
that's arrived.
And as you see there,
we're gonna add them into a map
and then use that store tallies
function to go through the map
and do the datastore updates.
Finally, delete the tasks.
So a failure
at any point in this,
is going to result in
either a retry,
if you were using
long running tasks
or the next indication
of cron,
picking up any of the tasks
that were actually lost
or could have been lost.
So the main advantages
to an approach like this
is to really limit your load
on datastore.
So if we were doing
one transaction per vote,
potentially
we could be doing
a 1,000 times
datastore operations
as we're doing now
in this approach.
And with that,
I'd like to hand over to Vivek
who is gonna tell you
all about how workers can run
outside of
Google App Engine.
Sahasranaman:
Can we switch?
Veme: Yes.
Sahasranaman:
So we're gonna talk
about something
slightly different,
and it's probably
like the first API
that really exists
on App Engine
that allows App Engine to be
accessed from outside.
And we think
that for task queues,
it's a very common use case
that there are things
you want to do that,
you know,
currently may not be
doable on App Engine,
or it might be easier for you
to do them outside.
You know, all image processing
is a good example.
You've got some image
processing stuff in--
So image processing
is an example.
OCR is another example.
For all of these things,
you probably have binaries
that you downloaded
from the Internet
and things that you can't run
easily in App Engine.
So what we provide
for these things is an API
that you can access
the pull queue or REST.
And this allows you
to run your workers
anywhere on the Internet.
So they can be on VMs.
They can be
on hosted machines.
They can be,
you know, anywhere.
And it allows, given that
these workers can run anywhere,
they can actually run
custom binaries,
they can run
image processing packages.
So for people who aren't
familiar with REST,
REST stands for
Representational State Transfer,
and it's a very common model
that a lot of Google APIs
are moving towards.
If people were here
at the Google storage
for the developer's talk
in the morning,
they also have REST API.
And REST basically models,
has a model for
collection resources,
and for the task queues,
we have basically a queue
and tasks as our collections.
And we allow workers
to lease and delete tasks
using the REST API.
And we still expect
that most of the insert calls
and the thing that actually
feeds into the queue
is happening from
inside App Engine.
It's, the first question
you would ask
when an API is made aware
of any of these things is,
how do you authenticate?
So how do you make sure that,
you know,
only legal guys can actually
call this API?
And the way we set that up is
that you can actually
specify an ACL.
And we'll see an example
of how that is set up.
You can specify in ACL
in queue.yaml
while you're uploading
an App Engine app.
And the API then makes sure
that only the guys
who are specified in the ACL
can actually access the API.
It uses OAuth,
which is a standard
authentication mechanism
which kind of avoids,
you know,
say keeping your passwords
in to do authentication,
that a lot of Google APIs
are also moving towards.
And we will see examples
of how this works.
So to get started with this,
there's an extra bit that you
need to specify in queue.yaml
or queue.xml
if you're doing Java.
It's called ACL.
And we'll see
a very specific example,
but basically you specify
just user app domain,
a list of those,
and all of those guys
are then authorized
to access your task queues.
And then you access the
REST API which is at that URL.
And Google is
moving to REST in a big way,
and a lot of APIs
are available,
and there's an open source
API client library
that you can use
to talk to these APIs.
And we've built a couple
of samples on top of these
that are available open source
from that link,
which are also at the end
of the slides.
And specifically,
there are two of them.
There's one which lets you
run a single command
against your queue,
just to make sure
that everything is working.
There's another one which kind
of runs in an infinite loop,
continuously pulls tasks
from your queue,
executes an arbitrary binary
for each of your tasks,
and then deletes the task.
This, we think, is another
very common pattern
that a lot of people
will want to use
when they're using
pull queues.
And both of these examples
are available.
We'll also use these examples
in the demos
that we're going to do.
So the first example I have
is probably the simplest example
that you can build,
and something that you can't do
in App Engine today,
which is very simple image
modification.
So App Engine has very
simple image API,
which lets you do small degrees
of transformation,
but we'll try to do something
that's just a little bit beyond
what App Engine can do today.
And the model is very simple.
The task
that we will create
will contain a single photo
in the payload
which will be uploaded
from an App Engine app.
And then workers running in VM
will actually execute
an image processing binary
on these tasks
and put it back
into App Engine.
I'll show you
the demo first.
And then come back to
how this thing is built.
So--
I'll pick an image--
and upload it.
What I also have
is a machine.
This is just
a standard machine.
It doesn't really matter
where this machine is running.
And on this machine,
I'm gonna basically
be running something
that can access
the API or REST.
So in this case, I'll run
this thing called the puller
which will continuously
access the queue
and will actually
execute the binary,
convert minus annotate
on the payload
and push it back
into App Engine.
And we will notice
that there's a processed image
that's come back.
So to kind of go into
a little bit more detail
into how this app
is constructed,
I'll kind of just lay it out
pictorially first for everyone.
So there's basically
an App Engine app,
and there's a worker
machine pull
which is outside
App Engine
that's trying to access
the pull queues.
So what happens is you first
insert your image in
as a user request handler,
that then writes the image
in a datastore
and then also queues up task
into the pull queue
which also contains this image
as the payload.
You've got a worker
machine pull
which is continuously
pulling this pull queue
and it will eventually notice
that there's a task available.
It'll lease this task
over the REST API,
execute its custom work,
whatever it needs to do.
In this particular case,
I've chosen to use
OAuth authenticated upload
to return the converted image
back into App Engine.
And there's a handler
that exists inside App Engine
that eventually writes it
back into datastore.
The OAuth authenticated upload
ensures that only
authenticated users
can actually access
the worker upload handle.
So the App Engine
side of things
looks very similar
to Nick's demo.
So I'm gonna kind of
skip over that part
and I'm gonna focus more
on how to set up the thing
that's outside App Engine.
So as mentioned before,
there's this ACL bit
that you need to set.
In this particular case,
I've chosen me and Nick
as the consumers
of this queue.
And we just specify those,
and then you write
an App Engine.
You write your App Engine code
to insert stuff
into the queue as before.
And then, you have to write
some code on the other side
to actually pull it
out of this queue.
As I mentioned before,
there's the API client library
which lets you
access all APIs
that are available over REST
in a very systematic way.
And this is available
in many languages.
It's available in
Python and Java.
In this specific example,
we choose Python, and in Python
because of the ability of Python
to generate code on a fly.
The API client can actually
call a URL,
get a description
of what the API looks like,
and generate
an object for you
on which you can
make a function call,
which eventually translates into
an API call on the interface.
So the way we do this
is import a build library
that's available
from API client
and give it the API
that we want to build.
And this will give us an object
which we can then use
to make an API call.
And it will just look like
a function call in Python.
The next thing
we want to try out
is to make sure
that this whole thing works.
And here,
I get an opportunity
to demonstrate
how the OAuth system works,
and how the thing that
I'm running outside App Engine
is actually figuring out,
is actually getting
a token from you,
and using that token
to authenticate you
back into the API.
So I will kill this...
and run this utility
which basically is trying to
lease one task from the queue.
If you notice, the first thing
that it does
is that it actually asks you to
go to this URL and authorize.
So what this is trying to do
is it's doing standard OAuth
and asking
for authorization for--
it's saying that there's
this command line utility,
Google API client by
task queue command line,
which is trying to access
an API on behalf of you
and you need to
grant access.
So if you do this, it will
give you a verification token
which I paste back
into my command line
and then I notice
that the API call goes through.
And just for simplicity,
this app is written
so that it actually caches
the token in a file
so you don't have to do this
over and over again
which is why my puller was
actually working without the--
without this step in my previous
iteration of the demo.
And then finally,
to the worker code,
so once you've got
authentication working,
what you need to do is
you need to take this object
that you created using
the API client libraries
that I described
two slides ago,
and just make an API call on it
and as I promised,
the API call looks
like a function call.
So, like, every verb
that you expose over the API
translates into
a function call in Python
and it looks quite nice.
It's like all you have to do
is you get a request which says
it's task API.lease
and you give it a few arguments
and just execute
this request.
This results
in a REST API call
with an OAuth token
happening to the backend.
And a response comes back
which is [indistinct]
representation of a task,
or of a series of tasks
in this case,
because lease can actually
give you more than one task.
And then, like, for people
who are familiar with Python,
all you do is you just
iterate away your tasks.
For each of your tasks,
I chose to execute
convert minus annotate
and post the output
back into my app,
and then eventually delete.
So things work out
very nicely in Python.
In Java, it's a little bit
more complicated
because you can't,
because Java deflection
only works at--
you can't do this code
generation kind of phase
in Java, so you have to
actually compile the,
your library
into your binary
rather than doing it all
at one time.
We will also see another example
which is slightly different.
So another you know,
very, like the second question
after OAuth that people
would ask about in API is,
how much can I pull
from this API?
The current answer to that
is about 100K.
So like you can actually,
you can have tasks
of a size of 100K
and you can pull
a maximum 100K out.
So the next question would be,
how do I do something bigger
than that?
So the standard
computer science answer to that
is to use a level
of indirection.
So what we will do is we will
actually use another app here
which actually
demonstrates that.
And you can use this,
you use several storage systems
to kind of do this level
of indirection.
In this particular case,
we choose to use Google
storage for developers,
which is also kind of talked
about in the morning today.
And it's an authenticated
system which,
where you can store either
an authenticated token
or use a predefined secret
that is shared
between Google storage
and yourself
to kind of authenticate.
And what we've done is
that we have the same token
stored between
inside App Engine
and between workers
that's outside App Engine,
so both these guys can basically
access the same buckets.
And just for fun, we've--
what we're trying to do here
is photo-stitching, which is
kind of now become commodity
and kind of work on phones
but just to make it
a little bit more fun,
I also chose some examples.
These are images that are taken
from the Street View project.
And what we will do is
we will ask the worker here
to stitch
a few images for us.
So like before,
I run a binary on my worker
which has now noticed that
there's a task in the queue
and got busy with it,
and will eventually finish
stitching these images.
This application also
is built a little bit--
continues to show you what the
app in the background is doing.
And if you notice
what it's doing is
it's actually writing
all output to bigstore
or to Google storage
for developers,
and both the App Engine app
and the worker outside
are able to access it.
And here's potentially
an interesting place
that a lot of people here
would probably know about.
It's kind of close to here.
And just for fun,
I'll do another one,
which is a little
more complicated.
I might stretch you guys
a little bit more.
And you notice
the worker pulls up,
pulls it up again
and starts off,
and once this--
And once this one finishes,
I'll give people
an opportunity to guess
where these images were taken.
I suppose you can only guess
once the stitching is done.
Okay.
And here we go.
Any ideas?
The guys who have
seen this demo before
are not allowed to answer,
and for the other guys,
there's a very small hint
of a very iconic monument.
Try again.
Someone said Sydney.
This is actually a view
from very close to
the Google Sydney office.
If you notice,
that's the Sydney Harbor Bridge
that you can see.
And this is an image
that was taken from
the Google Street View project
very close to the Google office.
So coming back to this app,
just to kind of show
this app pictorially again,
basically,
it's very similar
to the previous app
except that it uses
external storage system,
and uses a shared secret
between App Engine
and the worker pool
to access the storage
authenticated.
And in this case,
we happen to use Google storage
for developers.
You could use
lots of others.
There are several other similar
storage utilities available.
So to kind of recap,
there's basically a few things
that you need to worry about
when you use pull queues,
especially for users
of push queues
who are kind of used to
a degree of convenience.
There's,
scaling is a problem
that you need to worry about
yourself, the pull queues.
The benefit that it gives you is
that you can run these outside
and as well as
you can do things like
you can reduce
load of datastore,
and so on and so forth,
like Nick demonstrated.
But the number of workers
that you run is your problem.
There's no way that the queue
is a passive entity
in this case,
and it will,
and you have to figure out
how many workers to run.
There's an operation
on the REST API
in case you're workers
outside App Engine
which gives you statistics
on the number of tasks
in the queue,
so how many tasks
are there in the queue,
and how many have been
executed in the last hour,
and so on and so forth.
And that can potentially
give you some hints about,
you know, how many workers
you should be running.
If your queue
is backing up,
you will start seeing
that count rise
and maybe that will
give you a hint
that you should be
running more workers.
If your queue size
is at zero for a long time,
then maybe you should,
you know, get some workers down.
The second thing to talk about
is about choosing a lease.
So as Nick discussed,
if your tasks overrun the lease,
they're available
for leasing again
which means that another worker
will be able to pull them
and execute them,
which means that you will get
a lot of, you know,
duplication of work happening
if you choose a lease
that is too short.
So to start with, we suggest
that people should choose
close to the worst possible time
a worker can take.
So in that case,
you kind of reduce
the amount of
duplication of work.
At the cost of
a little bit of overhead
if your worker crashes,
but that should be okay
because you're probably doing
offline processing here anyway.
Another thing to think about
is about what your worker
is really doing.
Even with choosing
a very conservative lease,
it's possible
that sometimes your workers
might overrun the lease.
In that case, the same task
will get done more than once.
Although this, you know,
depending on how
you've got your things set up,
it might be relatively rare
or not.
But you know, we suggest
thinking about, you know,
whether you want your tasks
to be idempotent.
So like, if they execute
more than once,
they don't produce effects that,
you know, you don't,
you can't handle
in your application.
It would be,
if a repeat of a task
was to produce
exactly the same effect,
then you would be
basically ensured
against a task
executing more than once.
And finally, posting back
to App Engine from workers.
On the getting the task
out of App Engine side,
the REST API helps you.
It's authenticated.
On posting data back
to App Engine from workers,
you need to worry
about OAuth yourself,
and we saw two examples
of how that could be done.
App Engine inherently supports
OAuth on all its handlers.
So you can actually use
authenticated uploads
into App Engine, which is what
we did in our first example.
And you can also use
like an external storage
kind of system that--
and with a shared secret
to kind of protect
data transfer.
And that's it.
So we've got a bunch of links
and a lot of this code
is already available.
We've got both the samples
that we used in the demos
are actually up on the
App Engine's sample's code site.
And the rest API samples
are also available for you
to pull and use.
And there's documentation.
One of the things
I'd like to show people
is this thing called
the API explorer
which came out from the API team
which also kind of indicates
how you can use
like a description of the API
to actually kind of render
and actually run an API
from a browser.
So in this case,
the task API,
it's doing all this
by actually querying
what the API looks like,
and getting a description
of the API
and it knows exactly
how to make the call.
So, like, for example,
for the task API,
there are all these calls
that exist.
And in this case, if I choose
to do the lease call,
it knows that these are
the four parameters to fill.
In most of the calls
that we have on our API,
are authenticated calls,
so they're not public calls,
so it allows you to go
into this mode
which allows you to do private
access which did not work.
Oh, okay, well, actually,
okay, it did work.
So it--
and it automatically knows
that there's a scope
on this API
which is a task queue scope,
so the only thing you can do
on this API call
is access a task queue.
And now I can fill up
arguments very similar to--
and try to lease one task
out of that queue for 30 seconds
and you will actually see
a request go through
and response come back.
In this case,
my queue has no items.
So the lease returns nothing
but it's kind of like
a fun way of, you know,
actually trying out an API
from a browser
and figuring out
whether things work.
Questions?
Please come over
to the microphones
to ask your questions,
so that they can get recorded
on the video.
man: How many task queues
can I have now?
Veme:
You're allowed up to 100
if you have enabled billing
on your app.
Otherwise,
you can have 10.
man:
The other is, are tasks--
when App Engine
goes in maintenance mode,
are task queues
still available?
Veme: Yes,
they should be available.
man: I think you mentioned
the word "reduce,"
I think you said it was with
a small "r,"
not a capital "r."
Veme: Yes.
man: You've gone
through 41 slides
without mentioning
MapReduce.
Veme:
Yes, that's right,
but MapReduce
is still under development
and we're hoping
that pull queues themselves
may actually form part of
the solution for reducing.
man:
Okay, thanks.
Sahasranaman:
Just wanted to add,
that MapReduce and pull queues
are actually also in,
to think about
a slightly different--
a pull queue is also something
that kind of gives you
like a work flow
kind of system,
whereas MapReduce is more
like bulk processing.
man:
Could I add to the queue
in a transaction like
I can with the push queue?
Veme:
Yes.
Actually,
all of those operations
for adding transactional adds
are still supported.
Yes.
man: Also, can I relinquish
a lease once I've taken it?
Veme:
The way that you would do that
is simply to let it expire.
So stop working on it,
it expires,
someone else can get it.
woman: I may have missed
something, so I'll ask anyway.
I have two questions.
One is, do you see any value
to workers actually being
with REST
and be notified for tasks
so that they can pull it down
just to reduce the overhead?
And the second one is,
I know it's called queues,
but I'm wondering
is there any potential
for a Google space
like mechanism
so workers can actually
request by template
rather than just for the first
task in the queue?
Because right now,
it looks like you'd end up
having to set up separate queues
for each kind of task.
Sahasranaman: I think I'll let
you answer the second part
and I'll answer
the first part.
Veme: Yes. So we do have
several requests
on our issue tracker
for just the kinds of things
that you've mentioned.
We don't support them
just at the moment,
and we're certainly
working on a design,
but I really can't give you
more than that. But, yes.
woman: So does that mean
that's a yes for both of them?
Notifications?
Sahasranaman: No so I'll answer
the notification question.
woman:
Oh, okay.
Sahasranaman:
So the notifications question
is that basically, this is
something that our API team
is actually currently kind of
starting to work on.
None of our APIs
currently have notifications.
Like, Calendar doesn't
have notifications.
So there's a lot of APIs
that you could imagine--
and notifications and API
are really two sides
of the same coin.
woman:
Right.
Sahasranaman: So yeah, so
we are probably gonna have them
but they don't exist
right now.
woman:
Thanks.
Veme: All right. Well,
there's no more questions.
Thanks, everybody,
for coming.
Sahasranaman:
Thank you.